hot breath uh this one ties into what
we're just talking about being on the
road
is that cj asks what memories of the
road will flash through your mind
right before you die
[Laughter]
they will be i i can't remember exactly
where i was
like um in austin
texas at cap city a guy comes up to me
this was when i was touring that joke
about
this joke about my mom where a show we
did in l.a was cancelled and she
she's a teacher and she said snow day
and i have a joke about mom like you
know
sweet if you're an elementary school
teacher but if you're comic they think
you have cooking
and so she was like and that i wrote
that because a guy came up to me and
after a show in cap city and was like
um what did he say
oh my god i wrote the joke off of it i
can't remember
do you like i forget what it was it
was something like do you
ski or snow sports or something
[Music]
it was basically saying i thought he was
asking me about like some sort of
does it snow where you come i forget it
was something like this
i didn't get it because i don't do drugs
and i was like
what no is it he said something about
there's snow in texas and in my head i'm
like it's arid like what are we talking
about here
i was like no and then he left and later
somebody was like oh he was asking if he
wanted to do cocaine
and i had no clue and something later
when
that my mom really did say snow day i
was able to link that joke but
this i can't believe it's i've blanked
on what he said to me
what was the guy coming up to me after
the show asking me if i do coke
and no he didn't say do you party it was
something to do with snow
snow skiing who cares the point is that
moment
and then i was in madison wisconsin at
comedy on state
and this was when i was selling like old
albums i guess
i had hard albums and a guy was like can
you sign this
for me i'm gonna use it
like he was basically saying i'm gonna
use it to jerk off with and his wife was
right there
and she was like god damn it
let's go or something like that but it
was just basically a guy coming after me
with his wife and can you sign this so i
can use it later
and it was just like what it's not like
a sexy photo it's like just
anyway that um
[Music]
wait hold on was it saying oh moments on
the road flashing before my eyes
trying to think of other oh
um
uh there's this awesome chick that came
up to me after a show in indy and
i have like i said in this new special
there's abortion material
and uh she came up to buy a hat of mine
my new special is called girl daddy
and i sell these girl daddy hats and she
was like i'm gonna wear this to my
abortion next week and she opened up her
wallet and had like tons of cash in it
and she was like this is the money from
the guy paid for part of his portion of
whatever
paperwork so i was like that was an
awesome moment
um i talk about you know
um in this new hour
you know what it's like the relationship
between men and women and sex and
everyone's complaints and jokes about
the metoo movement and what it really
means and blah blah so
a guy in indianapolis came up to me with
his son who was about to head off to
college
and they were hammered and they were
together and they were like we got we
want to buy girl daddy hats
it was like and the guy the young guy
was like a lot of that stuff was really
good for me to hear
thank you you know like this or that it
was just great it was
just a great moment um
basically me teaching them about sex and
just calm down and
and uh stop letting these male comics
scare you about it
um i'm trying to think i think this is
some great moments that come to mind
yeah those are awesome